we're gonna begin with the latest on
vaping the FDA says teen vaping is an
epidemic and Joule lab CEO acknowledges
that his product is a big part of that
problem roughly one in five high school
students and nearly one in twenty middle
middle school students think of that
said they vaped in the last year only on
CBS this morning we spoke to Kevin burns
the CEO of Joule the largest east
cigarette company and we asked him what
we asked him what's being done to stop
underage vaping when you think of
underage vaping today youth vaping
what's it look like to you how big is
the crisis I think the problem is big
would you call it an epidemic I'm not
gonna use the same words it's others
have use but it's big and concerning and
it needs to be a lot lower than it is
today a crisis and emergency I think we
need to move with speed and urgency yeah
do you have a sense of how big a portion
of the underage market you guys are we
don't know specifically on that but I'm
sure you know a big portion of the
problem is attributed to Jule usage of
our products what do you say to those
families those parents about their teens
using this product as I've said this
before I'm sorry that their kids are
using the product and I have empathy for
them for what they're going through
dealing with their kids trying to go
through any kind of difficulties
especially in addiction to a product it
has nicotine Oh so when you say sorry
and you have said it before sorry for
what it was it an accident was it a
mistake how did this happen
well I said I'm sorry for the situation
they're in again there's never been an
you don't think Joule caused it well
some people could have used our product
but there's never an intent on the
company's part to target youth to grow
our business that's been the assertion
their family's suing you saying you went
after their kids as customers your
campaigns appeal to them and now they're
addicted to nicotine maybe for life how
do you plan to respond to that well you
know I don't think our campaign was ever
targeted to kids we don't need the
target youth to grow our business to be
successful in fulfill our mission part
of that mission is now keeping Jools
products away from underage shoppers so
you've got a fix for it you think
we have a solution which can it can work
on this so I'll take that Byrnes brought
us to a San Francisco convenience store
to show us their new initiative okay so
let me scan that an ID verification
system all right these IDs expired I
cannot sell it to you at this time I
apologize it prohibits cashiers from
selling jewel products to underage
shoppers and places limits on the amount
that people can buy you have to have a
valid ID the scheme to release the
transaction through the system so if
little brother walks in with his big
brothers ID and hands it to him and that
ID is expired
no go it's not gonna get a transaction
completely Jules says more than forty
thousand stores have committed to
implementing these new standards and
that it plans to stop distributing its
products to stores that aren't compliant
by 2021 they call it the strictest
verification standards for any age
restricted products in stores when I
hear you talking about all you're doing
here to combat underage use and I think
about your apology I'm sorry
to the parents who find their kids using
this product I'm sorry for the situation
they're in it sounds like you're putting
the blame on the families and on the
teenagers doesn't the blame reside with
jewel no yeah I don't want to give any
impression on blaming it on the families
I think you've got a category wide issue
we are in part we need to be part of the
solution we have to take a active
leadership role in being part of the
solution this follows previous efforts
by jewel to counter underage vaping
removing most flavors from stores
shutting down some social media accounts
and shifting its marketing to feature
former smokers with the things you've
done so far can you say today that you
think underage use will go down when the
next survey comes out can't say that
with certainty no I think there's other
factors that come into play
we're the only manufacturer that's
taking flavors out of retail there's
been an influx now of counterfeit and
compatible products coming into the
marketplace
online is still a challenge as a channel
so you think when the 2019 numbers come
out tnehews which is already at one in
five high school kids could go up again
I think you do up yeah that's a
possibility think of that another year
in which teen vaping numbers continue to
go up a couple things important to point
out there I had a fake ID in high school
this new system they have would have
beaten my fake ID so I wouldn't be
buying dual I wouldn't be able to second
thing you might have heard him mentioned
he has a teenage daughter he's got a
teenage son to his teenage daughter
didn't want him to work for Jul didn't
think it was a good company interesting
he brought her around to meet everybody
inside and and said she had to be
convinced that what they're about it
actually is public health and the big
takeaway here is he tries to take on all
questions really for the first time is
he believes he can convince the FDA and
hopefully America that jewel is a net
good for public health in this country
his argument is that they want to
provide a product that cigarette users
can use to wean themselves off of
cigarettes but why not make it a
prescription product or you have to go
to the doctor get a prescription to get
Joule rather than make it available for
everyone and people just start using the
product who don't smoke it's a great
question and maybe at some point the FDA
will push it in that direction but the
the Joule perspective right now is if if
you go into a convenience store and you
have the option of buying a cigarette
you want them to have just as much easy
access to the Joule alternative if
switching can work so look there are
millions of lives at risk and there are
millions of teenagers entangled in this
so the balance of the two is really
gonna dictate where this goes in the
years ahead